[Musik]
luft holen die sonne genießen unter
menschen sein endlich zum ersten mal
seit 51 tagen so lange dürften die über
65-jährigen in der türkei ihre wohnungen
nicht verlassen
zum schutz vor einer infektion mit dem
corona virus es ist sonntag der zehnte
meyer
heute gehören die straßen istanbuls ganz
allein den alpen
[Musik]
wäsche und cenelec und sie konnten es
kaum erwarten
die tochter und ihre familie müssen zu
hause bleiben versiegelt eine
ausgangssperre für nässe und china aber
ist das wie ein feiertag
[Musik]
das wetter ist wunderbar ich fühle mich
wie neu geboren und ich bin auch kaum
müde
ja das ist super für uns das ist wie
eine große belohnung
ich habe meine kinder und meine enkel
gesehen
ich habe ihnen von unten gefunden wir
haben uns der anordnung der regierung
gefügt sagt channel auch wenn wir nicht
verstanden haben warum sie uns
eingesperrt haben
[Musik]
frankreich italien deutschland die
europäischen länder die waren nicht so
streng
die haben das viel lockerer genommen und
warum nun weil wenn du deine maske trägt
und ausreichend abstand hältst dann
sollte das doch eigentlich kein problem
sein
aber bei uns haben sie so eine panik
gemacht
sie haben uns ja nicht einmal masken aus
teilen können
diese maske hier hat mir meine tochter
mitgebracht rückblick am 11 märz gibt
die türkische regierung den ersten
bestätigten corona fall bekannt nach und
nach beschließen präsident erdogan und
sein kabinett immer weitreichendere
schutzmaßnahmen zunächst werden die
grenzen geschlossen und die
auslandsflüge eingestellt dann geht es
um den schutz der risikogruppen menschen
mit vorerkrankungen und ältere ab 65
jahren die so die aufforderung sollten
doch tunlichst zu hause bleiben
auf empfehlung unserer beratungsgruppe
haben wir jetzt folgendes beschlossen
beginnend in ankara und istanbul werden
wir jetzt die älteren ab 65 jahren mit
machten und mit desinfektionsmitteln
versorgen
zwei tage später wird aus der bitte eine
anordnung des innenministeriums es
dauert etwas bis sich das ausgangsverbot
herumspricht die polizei kontrolliert
auf den straßen lässt sich die ausweise
zeigen schickt alle die über der
altersgrenze liegen nach hause
gib uns deine telefonnummer und sage uns
was du brauchst hängen nicht herum wir
bringen wir das was du brauchst schon
nach hause
schulen und universitäten sind bereits
geschlossen
ende märz verhängt die regierung dann
auch eine ausgangssperre für kinder und
jugendliche die sitzen seitdem zu hause
machen unterricht per internet oder mit
hilfe von fernseh kosen sechs wochen
lang gelten die strengen vorschriften
bis der präsident an anfang mai die
ersten lockerungen bekanntgeben die über
65-jährigen dürfen nun für einen
spaziergang das haus verlassen aber nur
an einem tag pro woche nur für vier
stunden und nur dann wenn für alle
anderen die ausgangssperre gilt
später werden wir das auch den unter
20-jährigen erlauben die wir dafür in
zwei altersgruppen aufteilen werden
zunächst aber geben wir den älteren die
möglichkeit sich draußen zu bewegen
zum ersten mal wird das der fall sein am
sonntag den 10 mai zwischen 11 und 15
uhr
was soll ich mit den vier stunden
auslauf fragt sich [ __ ] charakter jack
doch froh endlich mal wieder
rauszukommen ist er trotzdem
er nimmt uns mit zu dem ort den er
gerade am meisten vermisst den
fischmarkt von kwk
[Musik]
das sieht hier gerade alles ein wenig
trostlos aus hier ist das restaurant st
hier ist er in jedem dieser lokale haben
mindestens zehn angestellte gearbeitet
das sind alles menschen die seit 40 50
tagen kein geld mehr nach hause bringen
es ist für alle eine sehr sehr schwere
zeit im moment
[Musik]
schaut euch das an
normalerweise sind die gassen hier
samstags sonntags voller menschen die
kommen aus istanbul ist mit und anderen
städten hierher
das ist sonst ein schöner lebhafter
platz
während der ausgangssperre an den
wochenenden
obwohl nur die bäckereien öffnen
[Musik]
die leute kommen von weit her um hier
ihr brot zu kaufen
die haben ganz viele verschiedene sorten
auf dem fischmarkt haben alle geschäfte
zu nur diese bäckerei darf aufmachen und
das hier ist das feinkostgeschäft gäste
hier habe ich gearbeitet
doch weil ich über 65 jahre alt bin kann
ich hier nicht mehr zur arbeit kommen
ich fühle mich gerade nicht so gut weil
ich das echt vermisst habe hier
ich hoffe dass wir bald wieder zur
normalität zurückkehren und unseren
normalen alltag leben können
ich bin gerade echt in tränen nahe
so sieht er sonst aus der fischmarkt von
kadiköy diese bilder sind zwei jahre alt
gehört zum inventar im viertel kennt ihn
jeder nur im feinkostgeschäft gehört zu
den besten istanbuls einheimische
touristen eher laden ist immer voll und
buam in seinem element
ohne seinen job kann er nicht sein nicht
nur weil er damit seine rente aufbessert
sondern auch wegen der menschen
[Musik]
wochenlang allein zu hause zu sitzen
zehrt an den kräften eines mannes der
sich noch jung fühlt trotz seiner 71
jahre
seit 45 tagen mache ich nur hausarbeit
und die nimmt überhaupt kein ende
ich habe die teppiche gewaschen habe den
garten gemacht glaubt mir ich sage es
euch allen da draußen lernt die arbeit
die eure frauen leisten zu schätzen es
ist verdammt schwere arbeit seine eigene
frau ist seit elf jahren tot vier
töchter hat er und neun enkel
sein leben lang hat er gearbeitet als
lkw-fahrer als verkäufer nie hatte ich
mal mehr als 15 tage urlaub im jahr sagt
er
dank corona habe ich zum ersten mal mehr
als vier wochen urlaub am stück doch
genießen kann er das nicht
[Musik]
ich versuche was im garten zu machen
ich bastle kunstblumen ich nähe vor
lauter langeweile sogar sofa bezüge ich
wasche dies ich wusste dass ich putze
nur um mir irgendwie die zeit zu
vertreiben aber wie lange soll das noch
so gehen
mir ist langsam ziemlich langweilig ich
weiß nicht mehr was ich noch alles tun
soll wenn das noch länger dauert dann
fange ich das haus ab das hält doch
keiner aus
vielleicht kaufe ich mir ein zelt hat
einen wasserkessel einen sonnenschirm
dann habe ich einfach ab klemme mir das
zelt unter den arm und mache irgendwo
camping aber zu hause kann ich nicht
mehr bleiben ich habe die nase voll
nicht weit entfernt den kategorien einer
dachwohnung leben channel und national
grund zu auch hier sucht man nach einem
sinnvollen zeitvertreib
ich habe mich umgehört und geschaut was
man alles tun kann um zu helfen dann
habe ich was im internet gefunden und
habe mich mit denen in kontakt gesetzt
jetzt packe ich care pakete für die
krankenschwestern und die ärzte auf den
intensivstationen das schicken wir ihnen
dann so hat das alles angefangen weil
sie die wohnung nicht verlassen dürfen
ruft näscher einen kurierdienst und
wartet dort ich schicke euch die sachen
runter ich bin hier oben
ich lasse es euch runter
sowie national nun das essen für das
krankenhaus über gibt so bekommen sie
sonst ihre einkäufe vom laden gegenüber
mit dem beutel an der leine hinauf in
den vierten stock
eigentlich leben sie in einem haus an
der küste kamen mitte märz nach istanbul
zur beerdigung eines freundes hier haben
sie eine kleine stadt wohnung dann kam
corona seitdem sitzen sie hier fest ich
bin ein pensionierter offiziere
wenn wir nato übungen oder nationale
einsätze hatten musste ich manchmal 20
tage und mehr unter wasser verbringen
deswegen bin ich trainiert darin lange
zeit auf sehr engem raum zu verringern
aber ich mache mir sorgen um meine frau
da ist das nicht gewöhnt
sie ist wirklich am limit ich versuche
sie bei laune zu halten
versuche sie zum lachen zu bringen und
wir schauen uns zusammen käme
der erste monat war ganz okay aber jetzt
im zweiten monat tue ich mich echt
schwer
ich will raus mein körper will raus aber
mein kopf sagt nein mich und china
leiden denn viel lieber wären sie jetzt
in ihrem haus in canakkale an der küste
wir haben etliche anträge gestellt um
zurück zu fahren aber alle wurden
abgelehnt sein channel die provinz
grenzen sind dicht in kanada haben wir
tiere und viele obst und olivenbäume
niemand kann sich darum kümmern
und hier in istanbul können wir nicht
mal unsere familie sehen
wir gehören beide zur risikogruppe
deshalb besuchen wir auch die kinder
nicht obwohl sie nur ein stockwerk unter
uns wohnen
wir telefonieren mehr uhrzeit tochter
die dämme und die familie empfangen uns
an der tür reinkommen dürfen wir nicht
zu gefährlich nein wir gehen nicht hoch
wir sind jung wir können eine infektion
leichter wegstecken
aber für meine großeltern mit
chronischen vorerkrankungen ist es
riskant weil wir sie lieben schützen wir
sie wir telefonieren oder machen
videoanrufe und texten viel mit ihnen
das wird ja nicht auf immer so
weitergehen
dann steigt die tochter zum ersten mal
seit wochen die treppe zu den eltern
hoch lieber papa ist es zu hart euch zu
sehen und euch keinen kurs geben zu
können hier ist etwas zu essen für euch
wir haben uns so lange nicht gesehen
[Musik]
56 tage das ist ein witz es sind sogar
62 hätten wir kein whatsapp hätten wir
schon ganz vergessen wie er aussieht
normalerweise empfangen sie keinen
besuch in ihrer wohnung für uns haben
sie eine ausnahme gemacht
doch wir müssen vorsichtig sein und
abstand halten nachdem der gegangen sind
wird wäsche die ganze wohnung putzen und
desinfizieren nur kein risiko eingehen
das was mir am schwersten fällt ist dass
ich meiner freiheit beraubt werde ich
mag zu hause kein team machen ich mag es
draußen meinen tee zu trinken einen
kaffee und meine zigarette zu rauchen
und das darf ich jetzt nicht das setzt
mich sehr unter druck
ich laufe regelmäßig auf meinem balkon
so eineinhalb bis zwei kilometer am tag
der balkon ist zehn meter breit so baue
ich stresse damit meine muskeln fit
bleiben mache ich sport
das was mich am meisten stört ist jeden
mittwoch haben wir uns immer mit unseren
freunden in canakkale getroffen aber das
können wir halt jetzt nicht mehr
und das macht mich traurig sie vermissen
ihre freunde ihr zuhause ihre freiheit
sie fügen sich den maßnahmen ihrer
regierung dieser in der grund dafür dass
die türkei bislang relativ gut durch die
krise gekommen ist heißt es langsam
sollen die ausgangs verbote auch für
alle anderen gelockert werden es gibt
licht am ende des tunnels vielleicht
dürfen channel und national ballet in
ihr haus an der küste zurückkehren aber
sie werden sich wohl noch ein bisschen
gedulden müssen
[Musik]